It's time for a pick from the Little Yellow Book,
my personal guide to things I really want to share with you.
And today, it's a fresh seafood fest
delivered straight to your door!
(audience applauding)
I know! I love that!
Fantastic!
City Pier Seafood's easy entertaining kit.
I love this.
City Pier Seafood is a family-owned company
that does all the legwork to make sure
you're getting fresh, sustainably sourced seafood
wherever you are.
And in this kit,
you've got everything you need,
easily prepped, heat, serve, dinner, party, happen.
Bacon-wrapped shrimp, scallops, lobster crostini.
Ross, do you feel like a king?
Oh...
(mumbling with his mouth full)
That's a zero-point shrimp right there.
Usually she's force-feeding me carbs.
That's right.
So, look! I'm eating lean!
It's so true. I'm your literal nightmare.
I would argue with you, but she's right.
There's so much more on the City Pier Seafood website,
and everyone in our audience today is getting
a $200 City Pier Seafood gift card to shop...
(audience applauding)
...for your own feast!
(audience applauding and cheering)
Oh, my god. This one...
And we can all feel like a king.
I love, Ross, that you go for, like,
the zero-point shrimp,
and I'm like, "how about this one?"
Thank you, everybody, so much for choosing
to spend your time here today with us.
We make this show for you.
So take this good energy with you,
and we'll see you tomorrow?
(upbeat music)